Dear depression, we go way back.
I remember the first time I met you.
I was seven years old, a pigtailed lover of books,...
...teased for the sneakers my mother could barely afford.
When I was sad for the 49th day in a row,...
...I begged you to go away, but you would not leave.
You, depression, are my childhood friend.
The midnight voices in my head, a slick tongue.
You pretend to have the answers, but loving you got me sick.
But dare yourself, extraordinary human,...
...to run into joy screaming, "You cannot have me."
You cannot have me.
I am not my past.
I am worthy of love, I am worthy.
I am forgiving myself for not being strong enough to believe in myself.
I can tell you, I do not know who my father is,...
...but I would rather tell you I am letting go.
I am letting failure go.
I am letting loneliness go.
I will not give up.
You will not silence me.
Sincerely, Tanya.